before I get started I want to just
mention that the work I'm gonna talk
about is in collaboration with many
people mostly at the University of
Washington in the University of Maryland
and then the students who led most of
this work I include Meacham aloo drew
Jane
Kristen Williams and Holly Profeta who
was actually at the University of
Colorado so let's start by taking a
moment to consider augmented reality
what comes to mind when you think about
augmenting reality can you shout out
some technologies or applications
hololens ok so here are a few more
examples that that I've put together so
this is about 50 years ago and Ivan
Sutherlands sort of damocles and this
was perhaps the first head mounted
display it overlaid visual information
while not really on the real world but
it was see-through so you could also see
the real world so arguably augmented
reality and then about 25 years ago a
our research in HCI really started to
take off and so this is an example from
Steve finer and colleagues providing
augmented instructions here and now
today we actually see a are in
mainstream youths we have things like
heads-up displays head-mounted displays
like the hololens here and then of
course AR games which was also mentioned
by youth so this is poking mind go how
many how many people have played pokemon
go Oh quite a few ok so let's pause for
a moment and think about how AR can
support people with disabilities so
people with a range of physical sensory
and cognitive abilities the examples
that you shout it out as well as the
ones that I just showed you I think all
of them augment the the real world with
virtual concrete visual information and
that is typically what we think of when
we think of augmented reality but visual
information is of course not accessible
to blind users for example and so if you
look for a are examples and blind users
you might get things like audio
haptic output to describe you know who
is in the room or navigation
instructions and so on so auditory and
haptic modalities have been much less
explored in AR but could be and then we
don't have to focus only on concrete
information we could think about more
abstract information and that can be
particularly important for example an
augmenting cognitive abilities like
language production and then when we're
talking about augmenting abilities just
generally some enabling technologies
that I'd like you to keep in mind
include mainstream wearable devices
speech recognition which is greatly
improved in the past decade of course 3d
sound sensing and computer vision so
with all of this in mind for AR today I
want to talk to you about how we can use
AR to improve real-world accessibility
for people with disabilities and I think
this is an area that holds tremendous
opportunity and it has there's a lot of
exploration that can be done here so
there's some work but but sort of
relatively little so consider how AR
could address some of these questions
that have motivated our work how can we
sense and feedback sound information to
a person who is deaf or hard-of-hearing
how can we support a person with a
language impairment of finding difficult
words when needed or how can we augment
a blind person's sense of touch to help
interpret non tactile information so
toward the vision of improving a
real-world accessibility through
augmented reality we've followed three
threads of research the first is to
address accessibility challenges with
augmented railey technologies themselves
so making those technologies accessible
the second is to use existing
technologies and create new ones to
augment abilities in a way that
addresses real-world accessibility
problems and then the third thread of
work is to consider some of the
practical issues that we will need to
address if we want to actually have some
of our solutions be adopted in the real
world so these can include social
acceptability and privacy so I'm going
to spend most of my time on the second
and third threads in this talk but I
want to give you first
one example of this first thread of work
on to just emphasize the importance of
considering accessibility when we're
designing new AR technologies so in some
of our earlier work on AR and
accessibility we were looking at head
mounted display used by people with
motor impairments of course this is
Google glass here and the way that you
manually control Google glass is by
swiping or tapping on that side that
touchpad on the side of the device and
our very first study we recruited six
participants with motor impairments and
three of those six participants could
not actually touch the side of the
device they could not reach up and touch
it so that is obviously a big problem
for manual input you can use speech
input for this device but speech input
is not accessible to everyone for
example someone might have dysarthria
and of course it's not always
appropriate so even for the three
participants who could reach up and
touch the side of the device there were
still some issues this video clip here
is going to show a participant swiping
the side of the device but with such
force that he displaces the device and
then can no longer see the screen
properly alright so that is just one
quick example to emphasize the
importance of considering accessibility
when were creating new AR technologies
because if we don't make these
technologies accessible then we won't be
able to take advantage of the
opportunities that they also provide now
I want to turn to exploring some of
these opportunities and I'm going to
talk about three projects where we've
built and evaluated systems to augment
sound awareness language support and
physical touch starting with sound
awareness so in the US about 50% of
adults report some trouble hearing this
is in the US census and the rates of
disabling hearing loss which is the
exact phrase that's used are much lower
about 2% of adults aged 45 to 54 but
they increased substantially with age to
about 50% of adults 75 and older now
sound awareness has wide-ranging impacts
for people who are deaf or hard of
hearing from
safety-critical sounds like fire alarms
too mundane yet still useful sounds like
the closedrier ending a cycle to
conversations spoken conversations with
hearing conversation partners now
hearing aids and cochlear implants can
help with sound and speech recognition
but they do not eliminate hearing loss
and their success can vary based on a
number of factors like the user's a
hearing loss level their existing
linguistic abilities as well as training
and support so our goal on this project
is to oh yes not being as much of an
expert in this area
I wonder why would we not consider
something like a hearing aid or cochlear
implants an augmented reality system
that it like you know I include I've
always thought of it as a visual overlay
but you were taking a much broader
definition so does this fit in as an AR
system or not yeah I think it just
depends on how we need how broadly would
define AR so I couldn't be convinced to
- that a hearing aid or a cochlear
implant could be considered in a our
solution I mean once you think about
they are broadly then beyond this
typical setting of concrete visual
information and even registered in 3d
space which is a common definition that
they are then yeah there are lots of
there are lots of things that could be
considered they are I think that I that
that it gets especially exciting when we
start to introduce smarts into this it's
them and there certainly are hearing
aids that that provide more intelligent
filtering than others and so on yeah
inside the accessibility community those
kinds of things would not be considered
augmented reality though like people
wouldn't introduce these in their papers
as augmented reality systems information
other than the sound or speech for
example if you ever hear like a beep to
say a person's over there knocking
versus theirs or anything ever
additional information in the exists not
stuff like that yeah any such system
normally do they were augment
there's a version of which if you have
varying frequencies it'll push by the
frequencies that don't change it
interesting Thanks yeah I mean I think
that we're going to see sort of world
your coming together more than they are
currently and that's what the trend
trend is okay so so our goal in this
project is to provide always available
private and unobtrusive wearable sound
sensing and feedback and to do so in a
way that augments the user's existing
sound awareness strategies and that
could include using a hearing aid or
cochlear implant and and other cues so
this is a large project and I'm going to
talk about a few studies here the first
one is an exploratory study so here we
were interested in understanding who
among people who are deaf or hard of
hearing is interested in sound awareness
what preferences do they have for form
factors and feedback modalities and what
are some predicted social implications
that we might want to keep in mind when
we're designing new technologies so here
we conducted an online survey and we
recruited over 200 deaf and
hard-of-hearing participants and if you
look at their communication preferences
about half of them preferred oral or
spoken communication thirty percent
preferred sign language and then the
rest referred some mix of those two and
this is important for sound awareness
because you can imagine if somebody is
deaf embedded in Deaf culture prefer
sign language maybe lives at home with
other deaf sign language fluent family
members then they might not be as
interested in sound awareness as
somebody who has age-related hearing
loss and has been relying on sound for
decades so we had questions about sound
awareness interest form factors feedback
and social contexts so we showed
participants or described a set of
scenarios and here you can see some of
these that showed both speech and non
speech sounds occurring and then
feedback through visual and haptic
modalities on a smartphone a SmartWatch
and a head mounted
play overall we saw that there was high
interest in sound awareness in this
graph what you're seeing are the three
communication preference groups on the
bottom oral both in sign and then darker
colors indicate stronger interest and
sound so 73% across all the participants
were very or extremely interested in
sound awareness logistic regression
analysis to understand what demographic
factors were predictors for sound
awareness interest level showed that
this communication preference was the
most important predictor and was
significant so the sign language group
for example was less interested in sound
than the oral communication group but
still the sign language group more than
half of those people were at least
somewhat interested in sound in terms of
general interest in sound types and
sound characteristics the results here
largely reflect past work and cleaning
some of James Lind is from a while ago
and this thing so you know remember
Terry Matthews okay so this includes
urgent alerts voices directed at you
sound identity and sound direction and
of course there were there are more yep
white people who use sign language are
less interested than people who leave
these world communication that doesn't
like sleep did make a lot right so white
people who use sign language are less
interesting to sound that people whose
oral communication I think that I have
to do with a number of factors so that
it might have some in cultural identity
so you're in a culture that embedded
perhaps in a culture that does not rely
on sound that has developed other ways
of communicating and other ways of just
handling you know awareness of behaviors
in the world and it states in the world
and in and so that could be one reason I
mean there's some aspects of sound
awareness that this group was
particularly interested in like
real-time captions they were very
interested in the sign language group
was probably because spoken
communication was more difficult for
this group than for groups that had more
that actually obviously preferred smoke
in communication right so anyway so
they're different there's some different
characteristics going on there so in
terms of form factors and feedback
almost all participants wanted both
haptic and visual feedback and they most
commonly wanted this when asked about an
ideal setup on two different devices
haptic feedback on a SmartWatch and then
visual feedback on a head-mounted
display or a smartphone in terms of
social context of use we asked about for
context so use of a sound awareness
device when you're alone when you're
with family or friends when you're at
work or when you're with strangers and
most participants strongly agreed that a
sound awareness device would be useful
across all of these contexts there's
some indication that people who prefer
sign language may find it less useful
with family and friends again perhaps
because they're using sign language to
communicate and and may have some other
sound strategies don't need to rely on
sound the in terms of social
acceptability did you a question yeah
what is sound waves sound awareness
right means that if sounds are occurring
around you getting some information
about those sounds in some way that can
allow you to act but you know if you're
communicating with people or you there's
a door knock well so there's so a few
slides ago I had some I'm I went quickly
over this but we had asked people about
the different sounds that they were
interested in and there is some in
general it there are clear indications
that like urgent alert the voice is
directed at you that's those are things
that everyone wanted to know about but
there there is some difference in terms
of especially these three communication
groups in terms of some of the other
sounds once you get into things like
mechanical background noises inside or
birds chirping and other nature noises
like there are some differences there I
mean I think there's a there's this if
you step back and think about it there's
this bigger question of what why what's
the purpose of sound awareness it's
actually to understand something about
what's going on in the world and so you
know maybe you want to know there's a
bird chirping you don't need to know
that that there's a sound of a bird
chirping you know that somewhat nuance
but you could imagine if you had a
system that could know all of this stuff
that there might be that people some
people might prefer might not be like I
do not care about the sound at all I
just want to know what the thing is
that's happening and the sound is just
one way of getting at that so anyway I
think there's there's more to understand
here and I don't know that there are big
differences that were evident in this
study in turn people interpreting what
sound awareness is differently though oh
did I mention this social acceptability
thing okay so so the main significant
difference here is that that there was
lower significantly lower social
acceptability
when considering use of a sound
awareness device around strangers than
in the other three contexts so takeaways
for this study include high interest and
sound awareness
preference for visual and haptic
feedback often on separate devices and
then lower social acceptability with
greater social distance so now I want to
move on to supporting spoken social
interactions and we've looked at this in
two ways providing localization of sound
so where sound is coming from in a room
and then real-time captioning so for
localization people who are deaf or hard
of hearing make you some visual cues
when they are tied in gauging of spoken
conversation so this is called speech
reading or lip reading and so body
language facial expressions lip movement
and so on but being able to make use of
those those cues requires knowing where
to look so here's a quote from one of
our participants for example if one
person finishes talking I do not know
who to look at next in a group
conversation setting that is my problem
because hearing people can hear that who
the next person is and what they are
saying so our approach is to visualize
sound on a head-mounted display we want
to localize sound augment not substitute
the users existing sound awareness
strategies and then provide glanceable
support so there's some recent work a
recent trend of providing this
localization of sound and wearable
devices and what you see here is a wrist
worn device that provides Safi back in
four directions one issue is that you
need to look away from your conversation
partner in order to make use of that
information so imagine you are wearing
our head mounted display you're sitting
at a table with a bunch of other people
and then someone to your right talks a
sound visualization shows up on the
right of the device the display someone
across talks that shows up at the top of
the display and then someone comes in
the room behind you and that shows up at
the bottom of the display so you can
imagine designing these visualizations
in many different ways and what kind of
information do you present additionally
and so on so that's the first thing that
we looked at and I'm also going to talk
about a smaller second study where we
built and evaluated a working prototype
so let's start looking at the design of
these visualizations and this study were
recruited 24 participants with hearing
loss they completed semi-structured
interviews and we use the design probe
to elicit exploratory feedback on design
ideas
here we showed visualizations on Google
glass and on an iPad and participants
have an opportunity to sketch new
designs so the we looked at eight design
dimensions I'm not going to describe
them all in detail but I'll give you one
example which is directional granularity
so here we had four levels of
directional granularity from simply a
sound occurred or not to continuous
directional granularity and there are
implications here both were in terms of
utility and possibly cognitive load with
the the higher information granularity
conditions as well as for the sensing
hardware so if you don't need if you
need less precise directional
granularity then you can use fewer
microphones for example we evaluated
these ideas within two scenarios that
surround the table conversation scenario
and a classroom setting and then we
collect a preference data votes and as
well as opening and ended rationale so
an overall finding from this study is
that all 24 of the participants that the
idea of head mounted visualizations for
sound awareness was useful so this is
reflecting some of the earlier findings
as well but focused on head mounted
displays here's a quote from one
participant with profound hearing loss I
think it's a great idea it would reduce
the amount of time and effort to find
the individual speaking and would lead
to less content loss so this emphasizes
increased efficiency as well as more
meaningful communication potentially
another outcome from this study is this
set of design recommendations and so
these are based on those those
preference votes so for example for
directional granularity precision is
valued use high directional and
granularity and this is based on the
significant difference in terms of those
vote those preference votes and some of
the open-ended rationale that people
provided were for example the more
precise the direction the better it is
and then also some comments that
reflected the potential trade-offs with
cognitive load
and higher precision 8-level is easier
to locate than for level continuous is
to specific I think there's some open
questions there about what we actually
want to do with a working system another
example is that participants were
interested yes yes we did well because
so what we did was in our analysis we
focused on the quantitative preference
votes first and then we sort of grouped
together you know why what did people
say who preferred this level verse and
then what do people say over for this
level and I don't remember all the
details from the rationale but this
quote here the more precise the
direction the better it is is
representative of the eight direction
and continuous preferences and which was
the by far the most common kind of
sentiment yeah well yeah I don't
remember the details on that yeah but I
can look it up and talk to you more
about it later
yeah okay so another example is loudness
and oh yes Steve do you actually
localize the sand in space with some
accuracy and it asked yes participants
to you you know which how precise you
want them to be really big right word
how do you look like that sound with any
precision so we didn't do that at all in
this study this is this was just about
showing design probes but I will come
back to that question in a little bit
okay okay so loudness is also desired
some magnitude of sound in addition to
direction and then more advanced
features like automatic speech
recognition this differentiating between
speech and non speech sounds for example
we're also highly popular so I'm going
to come back to captioning actually
shortly okay so once we building on
these findings from this study we then
build a working system which we
evaluated with a smaller number of
participants
so here is to answer your question what
we had done at this stage was we use a
non wearable 3d sound sensor which which
it's it's about the size of a head
that's true on looks like the Death Star
isn't developed by one of our
collaborators for money there is salami
at the University of Maryland
anyway we connected this to laptop and a
smartphone then the head mounted display
and then we could actually visualize the
location of sounds in a room so this is
the set up for this particular study and
again we're non wearable sensor was fine
for at this stage in the research but we
are working on a wearable version right
now so here's a participant sitting at a
table wearing the head mounted display
and some research assistants around the
table and this is how the display looked
so there's an arrow here that's going to
move around as different people talk
right back in case unique I just
realized something we've never had a
completely successful tests with any
equipment hardly myself oh my okay so we
had four new participants with hearing
loss use two of the designs that were
most popular from study one and
participate in scripted and open-ended
group conversations with those research
assistants now here's a quote from one
of the participants on the experience of
wearing the device when someone walked
behind her and spoke so in feedback in
this study we saw some positive
reactions as well some concerns so for
example this approach would be helpful
because my hearing aid is not able to
point where the sound is coming from so
that localization advantage and and here
is a question about whether technology
communicated mediated communication is
always appropriate
so in this quote here my hearing friends
would want me to understand better by
real conversation rather than expecting
me to be looking at Google glass
okay so some takeaways from here are
that sound localization on a
head-mounted display shows promise for
people who are deaf or hard of hearing
and we have eight specific design
recommendations that deserve some
further attention within further work
with a working system and then currently
we are working on a wearable sensing
approach again this is with Romani to
respond at Marilyn and did you have
question this may be a limitation of
current technology so I'm wondering if
you think it is or not
my experience with folks who wear
hearing aids is that by sort of making
everything louder it also inhibits my
ability to sort of focus on a particular
part of my conversation in a loud room
and I'm wondering how many sort of false
positives this kind of thing would run
in right as well yeah I think there so
actually we just got an NSF medium on
this project so there because there is a
lot that we don't know about how to do
this I mean what sounds do you filter
out could we just filter based on
loudness do we need to know something
about identity do we show the latter
sounds in a different way than the
quieter ones did we just show speech
because you're in a conversation do we
eliminate all the non speech sounds in
the inner study actually there was some
paper rustling and one of the
participants said I want to know that
even though it's a conversation so there
there are lots of questions about how do
you actually do this feedback in a way
that is not that is useful and not
overly distracting and that probably
just changes based on context and how
does that work yeah lots of great
questions yeah okay in also with the
next thread of work that is this that's
the case too
okay so this thread of work we're
looking starting to look at real-time
captioning on a head-mounted display so
traditionally a real-time captioning
works with a human transit description
estándares shown on a laptop or a shared
display we're seeing more and more use
of automatic speech recognition these
days and this is actually good enough
that this is useful in many situations
also not useful in many situations and
can lead to miscommunication
and it's not as good as human
transcriptionist but but it's an
exciting development and then also more
applications on mobile devices now
regardless of whether using a laptop
share display or a mobile device an
issue that can arise is visual
dispersion and this is a picture from
Raja Kishan Naggar one of my
collaborators on this project at
Gallaudet University showing captions on
a students captions on a laptop for a
student in a classroom slides shown at
the front of the room there's also a
teacher someone there in the room there
are other students this student
themselves probably has a laptop or a
paper where they're taking notes so the
captions are just adding to this visual
load so what can head-mounted display
captions do to possibly reduce this
visual dispersion issue so in this work
we've been using microsoft hololens and
we've conducted a few studies so far so
the first one is an auto ethnographic
study in a stationary study and here we
looked at two early captioning designs
so one is a window where the captions
show up and then you can move that
window around and place it physically
attach it to physical things in the room
you can also resize it and you can
duplicate it so I could put one over
each of you know several people's heads
and then the second one is a simple
one-line caption but that moves within
your field of view so our first author
on this project drove Jane he's a
student at u-dub he's hard of hearing
and he used this system for seven
meetings and three lectures and a
quarter where he was also using laptop
based captioning in other lectures and
meetings his experience suggests that he
did feel that there was reduced visual
dispersion with the head mounted display
than with the laptop and that there were
trade-offs between these two designs
here so for example with the 3d the
design you could put a fix in 3d space
he would use it to maybe put below the
slides or on top of the instructors head
and then that way they wouldn't get in a
way of the slides or in the way of the
instructors face but then when here's in
situations where the speaker's were
moving around more than the other design
was more useful and before I get any
questions on it yes the hololens is not
comfortable to wear for a long periods
of time home so that was one of the
outcomes from his ethnography as well so
he tended to wear it for about 30 45
minutes 30 or 45 minutes and then really
wanted to take it off so can follow-up
work we refined the system and evaluated
it in a mobile context where a visual
attention is extremely important for
understanding your environment and make
sure you no trip for example one of the
motivating findings from this particular
study is that participants felt that
mobile conversations are especially
difficult because if they look away from
the conversation partner especially if
it's a hearing conversation partner that
person might not stop talking until your
visual attention can go back to them
whereas a deaf person might be more
likely to do that they're just used to
doing that so the head-mounted display
captions participants felt increased
intelligibility compared to a typical
mobile conversation experience and there
are sort of related to Michael's
question earlier many open design
questions about how to present
head-mounted display captions that were
highlighted in the participant feedback
like how to minimize distractions be
able to quickly toggle captions on or
off they're distracting if you're trying
to think for example better support eye
contact that hololens is very fairly
dark screen just as one example
displaying multiple speakers so anyway
many many questions around real-time
captions that I think are going to be
interesting to explore so in terms of
next steps we are building and
evaluating a wearable sensing approach
and an exploring visual and haptic
feedback designs we focus so far on only
visual but there's a desire for haptic
for sure and then more advanced
recognition features like ASR and
speaker identification and so on all
right so let's move on to a second
project this is on language support so
here we are working with people with
aphasia which is an acquired language
impairment most often due to a stroke
and affects about 2 million people in
the US so let me play you a little clip
here from a participant in our study who
has intact audio comprehension so he can
understand when the researcher then this
Kirstin Williams our lead student on
this project speaks to him but he has
trouble expressing himself tall tall
tall are there kinds of conversations
you would want to have yeah all kinds of
words in my mouth all kinds of words
come out all the time that I can't say
it good so he had trouble saying the
specific words who wanted to say which
is a problem that we're trying to
address here so communication strategies
for aphasia range from unaided
strategies like gestures and gaze some
of similar to what we were already
talking about paper based strategies
like drawing writing or communication
boards and then high-tech strategies on
computers and mobile devices and the way
these tend to work is that that the user
can look up a word and then either the
device can speak for them using
text-to-speech or they can say the word
themselves if it can prompt them to be
able to do that yes is this a production
issue like they can think the word or
recognize it when they look at it but
they can't say it it totally depends on
the person there are different kinds of
aphasia and some people with aphasia can
actually speak fairly fluently but it
doesn't necessarily make sense
other people have to have our speak more
like the individual that you saw there
and where they're having trouble coming
up with the specific words but the words
that they're using are meaningful and
then but then also it can vary in terms
of language modalities so some people
can read some people can understand
spoken language etc etc highly varied
okay um so so high tech adoption of AAC
devices remains low for individuals with
aphasia because these call attention to
the disability they tend to they can
replace rather than augment natural
speech so if their device is doing this
text to speech output then the user no
longer has to speak for themselves they
can divert gaze and impede use of visual
cues so we are exploring the extent to
which a head-mounted
can address these challenges of
attention replacing a speech and
diverting gaze so here's a scenario we
showed two participants in one of our
studies a woman's at the grocery store
she has a vocabulary need but she's
preloaded her grocery list onto this
device so she can look up that word and
get a private image text an auditory
prompt any of which maze for her only
own ability to say the word which she
can then go to independently we built a
proof of concept prototype on a head
matter display and this again gives that
picture text and sound prompt for a
hierarchy of words and because people
with aphasia often have right-sided
hemiparesis as a result of the stroke is
a weakness in the right side of their
body the touchpad on the side of Google
glass was hard to reach so we used a
wrist-worn touchpad here now we've
conducted a few studies and I'm going to
tell you about the second one a
qualitative lab and field evaluation
here we recruited 14 participants with
aphasia and they completed a
conversational task in the lab which is
autobiographical and we proceeded the
device with words related to their
recent vacations favorite foods and
hobbies they then went out to the field
and did a conversational task in the
grocery market
so this is where with an unfamiliar
conversation partner and is where help
is most needed because at home with an
in a more intimate partner you probably
have communication strategies already
built up so here's our field site in
Baltimore and the task was to ask for
this item which of course we didn't say
but it was a pumpkin and then to ask if
this bakery item a muffin contains this
common allergen nuts and then afterward
we did a semi-structured interview so
four findings here high-level theme was
glance ability so participants valued
this support for visual awareness for
example one person said my focus was
right on the money he the clerk was
standing right there and I can see him
and I can see the pumpkin
another person said oh yeah I could read
her nonverbal communication
a strong rule was also seen for this
kind of technology in a public context
that market versus lab settings so for
example busy place and friends or
enemies meaning strangers then the
head-mounted display really has a much
livelier or stronger role some
participants commented on feeling more
independent while using the device such
as I would never have thought to do that
myself go to the market no I would go
with my wife she would help me and I
would have to point and then finally
some participants commented on the
valuing the privacy nature of that
visual and auditory display that they
had mounted display provided so for
example I can't say it but I know what
it is so this device can say it for me
and then I'll say it so the that study
provided some positive suggestion that
this might be a useful approach to take
but it was qualitative and there was no
comparison to a status quo language
support so when a follow-up controlled
experiment we showed the same vocabulary
on a head-mounted display and a
smartphone so here is a participant
wearing the head-mounted display and
then we replace that touchpad that
restorin touchpad with a 3d printed
remote control with tactile indicators
so you don't have to look at it and then
we had 20 participants used had the
head-mounted display and the smartphone
and play a goldfish card game which
allowed for a constrained conversational
task some highlights from the findings
or that time per turn in the game was
significantly shorter with the
head-mounted display than the smartphone
so more efficient game communication and
that the private nature of the display
was valued so similar to that theme from
earlier however aha there with some
comments about the aesthetics of the
device and whether something like this
concern about whether something like
this would become used and used for
mainstream use or whether people would
just be looking at them and thinking
what do you have that on your head for
and this was probably around the time
when Google glass was starting well had
Google glass ultimately as you all know
we're
a fairly negative response but it was a
fantastic technology for exploring some
of these ideas and so we presented it as
an early prototype of what this might
look like but this way anyway around
that time - so in terms of takeaways the
head mounted display was used
successfully in a public context and the
private glanceable nature the display
was valued and in that controlled
experiment we saw increased
communication efficiency over the
smartphone so there are however many
open questions here that I would love to
work on although I'm not currently doing
it so I also encourage you I'll do it so
things like how much I'm gonna poke AB
you Larry to show what you know users
will benefit the most and we talked a
little bit about some of the variability
and users language abilities and then
related to the first question I think
automatic approaches context-sensitive
approaches for detecting detecting and
predicting the most useful vocabulary
and this is going to be particularly
important with a head-mounted display
compared to say a tablet or smartphone
where you might feel you know that
you're gonna be willing to navigate
through all kinds of information in your
AAC app now for this third project I
want to move on briefly tell you very
briefly tell you about the third project
which is different in that it doesn't
use a head-mounted display and here
we're augmenting physical touch with
computer vision
so imagine gliding your finger along
printed text and hearing the words read
out loud or keep feeling the shape of a
bar graph in a book we're touching a
piece of clothing and hearing a
description of that fabric so here's an
illustration of our approach we use a
tiny camera originally decided for
endoscopy it's one millimeter in
diameter but if you add lights to it it
is two millimeters in diameter so huge
and then we had Micro haptic actuators
on the finger or the wrist and our work
here has been largely application driven
so looking at instrumental activities of
daily living like reading support color
and texture recognition we've licked a
touch based control of mobile devices or
mobile information and then a haptic and
auditory feedback to guide the users
hand for these
their application areas so let me show
you two quick video clips this first one
is one of our early reading type and
prototypes for this is for a blind user
and where you can read a printed text on
a printed page and the system does OCR
and reads the text aloud
Amy would testify yeah okay and then in
this second example this is more recent
work actually we just presented this
lease turns the lead student of this
project is presented this last month at
the assets conference here this is for
low vision users and we're taking the
feed from the finger mounted camera and
we're magnifying it and doing some other
manipulations on it but in particular
the study that we presented is exploring
if you you present this information on a
hololens device what does it mean to be
able to attach that magnified view to
real world objects and so on so one of
our conditions had the view moving with
the within the users field of view like
that the magnified view as the user
moves our head here's another condition
where the view is vertical the magnified
view is vertical and it's affixed to the
top of the desk and then here it's
horizontal affixed to the other page of
the magazine that the person is reading
and then this one is where it's attached
to the top of the finger so it's
tracking the finger like a little bit
like a physical magnifier might work so
if you're interested in that you can
check out our us at the paper okay now I
want to turn to this last thread of work
on practical issues and just talk about
one study here briefly so like I said if
we want to have any of these
technologies actually adopted and used
in the real world we need to think about
issues like social acceptability and
privacy a lot of the technologies that
were that
might be particularly impactful for
people with disabilities in terms of
augmenting abilities might be sensing
all kinds of information about other
people in the environment and so that
that can lead to questions about privacy
and social acceptability so for example
here is a quote from one of our studies
reflecting a sentiment that comes up
from time to time and this is from a
participant with a motor impairment who
actually liked the technology that he
was trying out he said I don't want to
look like r2d2 I want people to see me
and not this wearable thing that you
have created so we started to look at
this this question of perceptions of
wearables and assistive technology along
with Shawn Kane and Holly Profeta at the
University of Colorado at the time so
perceptions like for wearable devices
changing norms same changes societal
norms around these devices like probably
many of you in this room have fitbit's
lots of people have fitbit's but at the
same time in the end Google glass people
did not like that it got banned from
places in fact there are these tensions
around the utility of the device your
self-image what do other people think
about when you when you're wearing this
thing and then the privacy and
distraction is some examples but then
with assistive technologies we also have
issues like the users sense of comfort
in using the device stigma and
misperceptions around assistive devices
here's a quote from Chanel Haren
walbrook that I quite like that that
kind of gets at all of this space which
is a blind person talking about their
mobile device and as a blind person yeah
maybe I don't want maybe I don't see it
the device but other people see it and I
want it to be I want to be you know just
as glamorous as the next guy so we
conducted a study with about 1,200 crowd
workers to look at this question of how
people perceive use of a head-mounted
display by person with a disability and
so the crowd workers viewed videos
head-mounted display use and then they
rated those videos on several dimensions
like whether it looked rude or awkward
to use the head-mounted display so here
we had two videos the first one
included a visible disability indicator
so the actor wear wore the head-mounted
display along with dark glasses and held
a white cane she's standing at a bus
stop and she's gonna be some taps and
swipes on that head-mounted display okay
so that's the one but that's what the
one video was like and the other one was
exactly the same except that it didn't
include those visible disability
indicators so in the first of four
experiments which is the only one that
I'm going to talk about for sake of time
we had a number of participants of view
each one one of the other of those
videos but we gave the same video
description for both groups the
following video shows a person at a bus
stop using a wearable computing device
so here are some results from this
experiment on the y x-axis we have our
different social acceptability
dimensions and on the y y-axis are the
ratings so higher numbers indicate
stronger agreement so overall the the
negative perceptions of the head-mounted
display use were significantly lower
with the visible disability indicators
than without so for example the video
with a person holding the white cane was
seen as significantly less awkward or
rude yes what's the baseline number
you're like what would it be if they
weren't wearing anything we did not have
that so that's a good quote if they
weren't wearing anything like just how
awkward are it is that to be standing at
the bus stop yeah my reaction is this
seems like a really small change and if
an effect size but maybe it's just that
you know the baseline numbers wouldn't
be that much lower anyway like I'm
wondering right maybe it's just that
there's not much for them to do they
can't go down much I'm just surprised
that like it's only slightly less
awkward
I mean significantly less but slightly
yeah you know one thing that I actually
don't remember is if if this is a
neutral in the middle oh sure but so if
this is so I'm probably relative results
here yeah so so it might be interpreted
as a to means variance I disagree that
this is rude I will have to look that up
although actually I
I were in the students I might do this
did anyone some students read this paper
recently do you remember
okay all right I've heard enough okay I
can tell you later um cuz then it gets
more rude if it's that's weird right
yeah so but I mean also the overall
trends here that are negative negative
perceptions are significantly lower this
is relative it would be interesting to
know what the baseline is to but this
relative experience the distinction
still exists regardless of what the
baseline is and then positive
perceptions were significantly higher so
it wasn't seem to be more appropriate or
useful and then there was some mixed
results around whether the person looked
like they were meeting dependent on the
device or whether they needed the device
okay
so across that for experiments and now
we'll have five right after this I'll go
start that up the user having a
disability improved perception of head
mounted display use and that there was a
further positive impact from disclosing
that the use was assistive so for
example saying that the device was being
used to read street signs versus the
person was checking their Facebook feed
now there is an important tension here
in that many people yes yeah apart from
helping the user so does that also like
influence my decision to say okay that's
I don't want to be recorded right I am
I'm sure it does yeah so that the
characteristics of the device and
whether whether the person thinks that
it might be recording them will probably
impact how people are reacting to this
question yeah so I you know the fact
that the head-mounted display in this
case has a camera which we mentioned
yeah so but you know about so this is so
these findings are specific to this kind
of
vice although my guess is that if we
replicated this these experiments with
different devices you'd still find
similar trends you know maybe the the
bars would be overall higher or lower or
you know as a baseline but you'd still
find similar trends so yes it's a good
question to think about so so
individuals that disabilities can be
sensitive to devices that draw unwanted
attention which I've already mentioned
and so I think there's an interesting
design challenge here to think about how
can you maybe give someone control over
disclosing whether a device is assistive
or not so that if they want to they can
they can do that and possibly tap into
this positive outcome you know if the
trade-offs are there for them okay so
that that study is just a first step in
and starting to explore these issues of
social acceptability and privacy and I
think there are huge ones and some of
the student conversations that I had
this morning we had some nice discussion
around some of those issues so it's good
to see that a lot of people are thinking
about them so toward the I think that
overall augmented reality holds
tremendous potential for improving
real-world accessibility for people with
disabilities and to get there that we
need to think about all three of these
threads of work so we need to make sure
that emerging technologies are
accessible to people with a wide range
of abilities and then we can think about
how we can use those and create new
technologies to augment abilities in a
way that addresses real-world
accessibility challenges but also all
the while while keeping in mind issues
of social acceptability and privacy so
that we get something in the end that
people will want to use it would just be
very interesting to see how all of this
plays out over the coming decade or two
really and what kind of broader
applicability there will be to some of
these solutions so on that note I would
like to think my collaborators and
funding sources and if you have any
further questions we have a few minutes
left
you